But we know that there's still work to be done.
So that new breakthroughs in science and technology...
...can lead to jobs on both sides of the Pacific,...
...and security from a warming planet.
So that we can reverse the spread of deadly weapons.
And on a divided peninsula, the people of South can be free from fear,...
...and those in the North can live free from want.
So that a young girl can be valued not for her body, but for her mind.
And so that young people everywhere can go as far as their talent,...
...their drive, and their choices will take them.
None of these will come easy...
...nor without setback or struggle.
But at this moment of renewal,...
...in this land of miracles,...
...history tells us it is possible.
This is the America's agenda.
This is the purpose of our partnership with Japan...
...and with the nations, and peoples of this region.
And there must be no doubt: As America's first Pacific president,...
...I promise you that this Pacific nation will strengthen and sustain our leadership...
...in this vitally important part of the world.
Thank you very much.